not only a violation of American law and
civil liberties it's actually a
violation of the Bible the Bible
instructs Judges two things don't take
bribes that's obvious but the number one
thing is don't recognize faces and uh
that's exactly right yes do not favor
anyone in a court yes that's exactly
right yes continue sorry
no that's and that's why it violates
every core of American value yeah well
fortunately or unfortunately I guess if
you like this argument the Bible is not
controlling the law in this instance
thankfully although if it were up to
Republicans the Bible would actually be
the law of the land and that's a
horrifying reality hypothetically if
there were a court that would hear a
so-called Bible violation then the
Republican party also wouldn't be able
to exist since they regularly violate
the principles of the Bible despite
claiming allegiance to it but that's a
different issue